every morning I wake up it's not just
about working out but for me working out
has been a very big part of my mental
growth so for me if I am not challenging
myself every day and I swear to God
people will not believe it I was over
almost 300 pounds twice in my life so
people can put anything they want to in
their head I did realize one thing the
things I don't enjoy that I still do
that's where growth is at I woke up and
I just got to London and I don't know
where to run here it's very difficult to
run around this place so someone said
hey you can run around out here like
around this one mile block and I'm like
you know what I'm not doing that so I
went down to the gym and there's this
like crazy elliptical trainer but it's
not a normal elliptical Trader it's one
that you like almost self-power so I got
on that thing and I realized man it
sucks and that's like two minutes like I
don't want to do this so right then I
realized it looks like we're gonna be
here for a while so I did that for two
hours and 45 minutes I said well since
we're my mind went there I redirected it
and said just for having that weak
thought I want my mind to know who's in
charge so for the better part of 26
years my mind wasn't charged with me
which is why I made all these horrible
decisions once you take control of your
mind you start making decisions for
yourself versus your mind making
decisions for you Hey Kevin Carmichael
and I make these videos because as a
young entrepreneur I struggle to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories motivation today so today let's
learn some of the routines and habits of
the wealthy enjoy
thank you
habit number two is get your house in
order with Jordan Peterson one of the
chapters of my books is is focused on
putting your house in order it's like
well how do you start make your bed
you know I I it actually took me quite a
long time in my life before I made my
bed regularly in the morning most of my
life whispered in pretty good order but
that was one thing I didn't have in
order my call clothes in my closet as
well all that's in order not all of it
I'm cleaning out some drawers right now
but
look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look it's like okay I'm
in my room do I like this room no it
bugs me okay why well the Pain's peeling
there and it's dusty there and the
carpet's dirty and that corner is kind
of ugly and the light there isn't very
good and my clothes closet's a mess so I
don't even like to open it
um okay that's a lot of problems
that sucks that's a lot of opportunity
pick something and fix it something that
bugs you yeah but not too much so it the
rule is pick something you know would
make pick a problem
pick a solution to it that you know
wouldn't help
that you could do
that you would do so you have to
negotiate with yourself it's like well I
won't clean up this room how do you know
I've been in here for 10 years and I've
never cleaned it up it's like well
obviously that's too big a dragon for
you would you clean one drawer
find out
and so imagine now you want to be happy
when you open that drawer and you think
well that's stupid it's like is it
maybe it's your sock drawer which I
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way you're gonna you're gonna open
that every morning
so that's like 30 seconds of your life
every day
okay so that's three minutes uh
week that's 12 minutes a month that's
two hours a year so maybe your life is
made out of you've got 16 hours a day
let's figure this out 5 12 in an hour 12
in an hour
144 in 12 hours yeah let's say 200 205
minute chunks that's your life ladies
and gentlemen Jordan Peterson did just
some math how many five-minute chunks
there are in a day that's pretty
accurate it's approximately right so you
got 200 five minute chunks and they
repeat a lot of them repeat
so if you get every one of those right
they're trivial right who cares what my
sock drawer looks like it's like fair
enough man but that's your life the
things you repeat every day
the mundane things think I could get all
those mundane things right that's the
game rules it's like now all the mundane
is in place
now you can play because all the
mundane's in place habit number three is
shift your identity with Tony Robbins I
have this theory that you know I think
children are happier than adults for the
most part because they operate out of
imagination Vision dreams that's their
prism and at some age it could even be
very young for so if you go through
childhood trauma or whatever it might be
but at some age almost all people 99
start to operate out of history and
memory and that's sort of their filter
or their pattern or their life it's
history and memory and I am asked often
how do I break that pattern I think this
all begins when you have fear you go to
history and memory and then they're
telling you what to believe how does one
begin to operate out of their
imagination imagine new skills imagine a
new life uncover their version of their
own genius how does somebody do that
Tony what's a skill or a strategy that
you would recommend to somebody says I
need to flip from this history and
memory these patterns I have to creating
new ones and I think that starts in your
imagination how does somebody do that
you have to shift your your physiology
first if you try to paint a compelling
future you know why are people depressed
one of the main reasons people repressed
is they don't have a compelling future
in other words you can deal with any
tough today if you have a compelling
tomorrow anybody can do that but today
people think oh my God I can't go
outside oh my God oh my choices are
taken away oh my God we're all going to
dive in 12 years because an
environmental crisis which is total
but there are people that have
been taught this and they're kids today
they're saying I'm not going to have
pain I'm not going to have children
because this is the world I'm entered
into because they have no compelling
future but if you try to paint a
compelling future when a person is in a
lowered energy state it won't work
they'll just reject it because in a
lowered State your brain goes into
survival mechanisms and the survival
mechanism you're always looking for
what's wrong what do I have to fight or
would I have to fly from or would I have
to freeze and hope it don't hurt us
that's the part of your brain that's 2
million years old and it's well wired
but we don't have a saber-toothed tiger
to deal with so now we worry about what
people will say to us or will we have
enough money or what somebody's going to
write about you in social media and we
have a similar reaction the way you
overcome that is the way you drive your
nervous system so I'll give you an
example when I was at my worst and I was
in a place where I gained 38 pounds and
I was feeling sorry for myself and I
come home one night literally I ran out
of gas on Pacific Coast Highway in
Venice I had a little apartment down
there and I didn't run a gas because you
know I forgot to fill the tank I
literally had no money I pulled over
locked the car and prayed they didn't
get towed because towed me 50 bucks I
didn't have 50 bucks and then I walked a
couple miles home
and I lived there on Pacific Avenue 2516
Pacific Avenue apartment 3A if you ever
want to go by I did recently it's pretty
funny but anyway I walk up the stairs as
a sun setting and there's a note typed
and stapled on my door and I don't know
if you've ever had to enjoy of having
one of these experiences in your youth
but it basically says you've not paid
your rent remove yourself and your
things if you don't pay within three
days the sheriff will take your stuff
and you will lose everything right
so I opened the door I go into this
place and I
I lit a candle and I I didn't light it
because I was spiritual I literally
because I also not paid my electric bill
it's a true story so I'm reading by
candlelight my eviction notice is how
low I gotten and then if that wasn't
enough I get this banging on the door
and I got three locks because I haven't
paid anybody right I'm looking through
and it's a friend I've not seen in a
couple years and I got a beer belly on
me and I've grown out you know this
Shaggy Little Beard and I was just in
the worst shape uh open the door parsley
what do you want he's like Tony it's me
you know I let him in he goes to my
house which is this little four to
square foot bachelor apartment you can't
even turn around I'm cooking on a on a
hot plate on the trash can I'm washing
my dishes in the bathtub and so after he
left I was so humiliated the whole thing
it's just it's like I gotta do something
I didn't know what I was doing there but
now I understand what I did I hit rock
bottom and it's like who I am is more
than what I'm living spiritually
mentally emotionally physically so I'm
old enough to have had a walk man I
think you might have had one absolutely
and you got to really love your music in
those days right because you had one
cassette in there so I took this group
called heart and it put
I'm going to run this beach till I spit
up blood I'm just and I did I ran as
hard as I could and when I thought I
couldn't do any more I ran harder and I
got to the end of it and I had left this
journal on the ground I drew a line down
the middle I wrote everything on that
list that I really
hated that was in my life which was most
of my life and then everything I was
committed to changing and I didn't have
all the skills and tools I had today but
I had changed the ignition it's like you
got the greatest computer in the world
there's not enough electricity your
screen's gonna be messed up without that
energy change yes you're really not
going to make the change that's why
everyone comes to one of my seminars you
know it's a physical experience you're
not sitting on your ass for you know 12
hours you're going 12 hours a day for
three or four days now people are at
home in 100 countries and they're going
Full Tilt like they're in a stadium for
full time and all of a sudden their
energy changes well in that place now we
can start to create this compelling
future now we can start to make the end
your nervous system says I'm ready you
know Stanford did a study they came to
me during the pandemic that's
fascinating they said Tony we had two
people go through your date with Destiny
a little six day seminar I do and they
said they're both clinically depressed
and they have no symptoms of depression
you're never saying like it you know
what data you have on this I said well
thousands and thousands tens of
thousands of testimonials you go no but
like scientific Dad I said that's not my
focus they said do you mind if we did a
study and then they showed me something
fascinating
40 of the people that get treatment for
depression and by the way depression has
gone through the roof since covid and
since all those limitations I know you
know suicide's gone through the roof and
it's horrific but only 40 get better
through treatment of drugs and therapy
right ssris you know Prozac Zoloft all
these things right 60 don't get
announced better of the 40 to get better
on average Across The Meta studies they
find they get about 50
50 as they were now some people get
totally better some not at all but
that's the average I said that's not
much better than a placebo they said
you're right I said well what's the best
you've ever seen they said two years ago
Johns Hopkins did a study where they
took people for 30 days of psilocybin
magic mushrooms and therapy for 30
straight days it got results that were
four times greater than ever seen in
history 53 of the people 30 days later
had no symptoms never say anything alike
it but psilocybin's illegal it's not
really duplicatable so they said what if
we model their study we'll use the exact
same criteria but we'll have you with no
drugs and have your people go through
the seminar we'll send people in that
are clinically depressed and so forth
and so they did it and the study with
the results were so profound they sent
the data out to two different
organizations blinded to get the data
back because they wanted to make sure it
was accurate before they reported it 100
of the people 30 days later after date
with Destiny had no symptoms of
depression but even better 19 of those
people had suicidal ideation none had
suicidal ideation 11 months later 11
months after one week they've changed so
much their negative emotions had dropped
72 percent their positive emotions up 51
and now this last week uh two weeks ago
I had another date with Destiny and they
did a study with 750 people with the
largest study of its type but why does
it work because we're not only helping
people shift the way they perceive the
world like you don't experience life you
experience the life you focus on yes if
you're focused on things that piss you
off you have to be deleting the things
you could be grateful for if you're
grateful you're deleting things that can
piss you off right so by changing their
beliefs and values they do this not me
there's a huge shift but it's also the
biochemical change so they track my body
for three years and they found crazy
like you know you know because you're
you're an athlete but you know I jump a
thousand times in an average program on
one day and I wait you know 285 pounds
so every time I come down it's four
times your body weight so imagine a
thousand pounds times a thousand jumps
it's a million pounds of pressure so I
did my bone density and they go these
are humans you know this is great
athletes this is you and everything like
it's like I'm a gorilla from just the
Demand right if you've been running with
a friend and you can't talk anymore it's
because your lactate is at four I'm in
18 and still speaking great here's the
most interesting thing they track my
audience and me and they found something
really fascinating there's a group that
does studies on like Tom Brady on the
Tampa Bay Lightning that's one multiple
times in the you know the the what he
called Stanley Cup and they found
there's a place biochemically that
people who are under stress perform at
the highest level it's why they win and
they call it the championship uh
bloodstream and what happens is your
testosterone surges so you have this
incredible drive but your your cortisol
which is the stress hormone drops to the
ground so you think so clearly that's
why Tom Brady's down by 14 with two
minutes left and he comes back to win
right well I produce that in my body but
what's even more fascinating if you know
about mirror neurons everybody in the
seminar literally because they do the
people around the world at home and they
mirror neurons exactly the same
biochemical change that's why a year
later the change is there if I said
where were you on 9 11 everybody knows
even the foreign countries they'll
remember who they were with what they
saw but if I say were you on 811
most people don't know because
information without emotion is barely
remembered so I make sure those are
merged and that's why we get these
lasting changes so it's not enough to
just understand what to do or paint a
compelling future there has to be a
shift in your identity in the way in
which you feel physically and that's why
the combination is so critical also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there habit number four is measure your
performance with
is that there needs to be an alarm clock
where performance is measured
performance improves secondarily the
more you can shrink the time frame where
you measure performance the better
chance you can have to alter that
performance and improve it so what do
most people do they measure their
performance the average people in the
world measure their performance at the
end of every year
New Year's Eve right they take an
account but here's my life
here's what I accomplished here's what I
didn't get done and once a year they
take a look at themselves they make an
adjustment and their performance
improves they measure their performance
they measure their results and then they
make an adjustment so they adjust about
once a year pretty good performers
shrink the time frame at the end of
every month most companies kind of do an
inventory most people do an inventory
they look at their books they look at
the profit and loss they look at their
schedule and they make an adjustment
after they measure that performance at
the end of the month really good people
kind of get together on a Sunday night
if they're pretty good performers once a
week they measure their performance they
make adjustments and they move on weekly
and then there's really top level
performers and they do at the end of
every day don't they the end of every
day they sit back they look at their
calendar they look at the results and
they measure the performance daily well
who do you think is going to do better
the person who measures it once a year
once a month once a week or once a day
we all know the better adjustments
they've Shrunk the time frames down they
adjust they get better they improve
daily and then there's the max out one
percent of one percent performers and
they have a clock that goes off every
hour
every hour in their head the alarm goes
off in my mind it's sort of weird but it
works I'm addicted to it now about every
hour the top of every hour at 11 A.M
it's funny my mind just knows what did I
do to move closer to my goals what did I
do to move closer to my outcomes if I
achieved the things on my to-do list
today have I achieved my biggest and
baddest outcomes of the day and every
hour did I move closer did I move closer
what adjustments do I need to make what
do I need to celebrate what tweaks
what's been accomplished so far an
hourly alarm clock goes off in your head
if you can get to the point where you
just begin to practice it maybe for now
you program this thing to go off every
hour just to remind you what did you get
accomplished maybe when that hour goes
off you know what flashes on the screen
your outcomes and your goals hourly the
alarm goes off hourly the alarm goes off
it'll begin to train you to begin to
measure the time frame of your
performance every hour now let me ask
you a question there's a group of people
that measure their performance their
race their marathon is once a year then
there's those that do it once a month
that make adjustments and measure where
they are and increase effort than those
that do it monthly weekly daily hourly I
can tell you that I run many days and I
measure for my performance hourly it
will transform your life you'll become
more productive in your family in your
personal relationships in your faith in
your business and your Fitness in your
nutrition and your money in every area
if just something goes off every by the
way it's a five second just reminder am
I move closer to my outcome if I move
closer to my to-do list today what
adjustments do I need to make you'll be
reminded at that time of someone you
forgot to call an email you didn't
return a meeting you haven't asked for
yet but something you were supposed to
eat hydrate whatever it is if you can
begin to have that alarm just go it's
just five seconds it's just every hour
it's just five seconds and I'll tell you
it happens to me constantly now and I
know that one of the reasons my life has
improved is because I've Shrunk the time
frames down of where I measure my
results right where I recalibrate where
I course correct where I make an
adjustment where I realize I'm behind or
I've made a mistake and I improve a
performance and so so far can you
imagine if you started just being a
bigger hurry
and you had perception correct about how
close you really are to your goal the
difference in winning and losing is this
much it's like a veil and when you
remove that Veil you see my gosh I'm so
much closer I promise you one of the
things that you suffer from isn't just
like a lack of vision and Clarity I wish
you more clarity and more specificity in
your vision and I wish you more
proximity that you knew how much closer
you were to achievement than you think
you are in fact it's the fact that you
think you're so far away from achieving
these things that's causing them to
constantly stay that far away from you
because you're not running fast enough
towards them you're not measuring them
fast enough you're killing your goals
and Your Dreams by thinking they're so
far away it kills everything if you knew
how close you really were you'd run so
much faster how about number five is
work less achieve more with John
assarath how do you do less and achieve
more is it possible
to do less and achieve more what do you
think possible to do less and achieve
more is there a difference between
activity and productivity the whole
concept of working hard
I think goes back you know into the into
the 40s and 50s when people were
laboring in fields and laboring in
factories and you had to go in and put
in A Hard Day's work or a good day's
work so ask yourself this question is it
possible to work less and achieve more
is it possible to work less and achieve
more yes or no let me give you a very
very quick example of what I mean how
many of you and you've seen me do this
in the past how many of you have ever
tried to solve the Rubik's Cube
and you may try to solve the Rubik's
Cube ever now why is it that you can
work really hard trying to solve the
Rubik's Cube and never solve it there's
over a million different moves that you
can make
with this three by three by three
Rubik's Cube over a million possible
moves this way that way two up two down
two around
so why is it that you can work hard and
do more and Achieve less
anybody ever solve the Rubik's cube
right you tried you were bored right you
were born because of so many possible
options
is it possible that you have some
disempowering or bad habits around
working hard but maybe you're not being
efficient and maybe you're not being
smart
maybe is that possible so I want to give
you a few things that you can do to work
less and achieve more so is the
algorithm to solve the Rubik's Cube
readily available if you are committed
to solving the Rubik's Cube is it
readily available
if for example you go to YouTube and you
have somebody walk you through the exact
steps you need to take that's one way to
go from trying a lot of different
possibilities
right to finding out a path to achieving
the goal faster do you think if somebody
showed you the algorithm or the steps
it would be faster and easier so there
is one example right of how can you work
less to achieve more and that's called
what do they may tell me what that's
called but other than being smart what's
it called other than being smart isn't
that called modeling
isn't that called modeling we model the
behavior that's already been proven to
work that's called modeling so what most
people do is they'll take something like
the Rubik's Cube and they'll just keep
trying something keep trying something
keep trying something and it won't work
so they put it down and they get bored
or they get tired or they get frustrated
but that's also called yes many of you
are saying I'm on Instagram here and
Facebook here right many of you are
calling that efficient so here's my
question for you are you being efficient
in every one of your roles for example
are you being efficient
at earning money
do we know how
to earn more money if you are committed
to earning more money do you know how to
earn my do you know the exact steps to
earn more money today this week and this
month do you know how if you want to
release weight and keep it off
do you know the exact formula for the
food you should eat how many calories
how much sleep you need and how much of
a caloric burn you need per day to be in
a deficit to release weight and keep it
off is the answer readily available if
you are committed
like think about this right how do you
work less and achieve more
right the answer is first
you see yourself achieving the result
that you want right let's go internally
first would you agree with that let's go
internally first and Dino why don't you
mix money with weight it's about
achieving a goal
right so for achieving a goal right and
so when we are looking to achieve any
goal would you agree that there's a way
of thinking that when you think that way
okay it is the right way of thinking
would you also agree that there's an
emotional state that you need to be in
and even though you may be frustrated at
first frustration actually leads to the
release of cortisol which is the stress
hormone and would you agree that when
we're frustrated we have a little bit of
adrenaline or cortisol in our system
that's actually a good way to achieve a
goal because we have the extra energy of
the stress hormone a lot of people try
to stay away from being stressed but a
little bit of stress is actually good so
here's what I like to do number one
if you want to stop trying so hard and
you want to achieve more by doing less
stop just trying to do
here's what you need to do first you
start off number one with getting a
vision in your mind of the end state
that you want this is what you might
have but this is what you want this is
what the end state is so the first thing
we always want to do is we want to give
our brain A visual representation of
whatever it is that we want to achieve
completed we may not know how to achieve
it yet but that doesn't belong in that
step so step number one is look at the
visual that you want whether it's for
your health for money or business or
relationship see it in its end State
part one part two
how important do you think self-talk is
how you talk to yourself right so oh my
God this is so hard I can't figure it
out should I do this left should I do
this right should I go two at a time
should I go left left first and then to
the right maybe I should do in my left
no that is disempowering self-talk
trying to figure it out on the fly when
we're dealing with with self-talk
questions are the key to the bio
computers genius let me repeat questions
are the key to your bio computers genius
so let me ask you all a question
it's not positive self-talk necessarily
Joy but self-talk is the key to opening
up your brain stuff so what is one
empowering question that you could ask
yourself to make the behavior that you
take
a smart Behavior so Joy says how can I
succeed right where can I find the
algorithm to solve this who has the
algorithm is it on Google is it in a
book is it through a coach a consultant
who has already solved what I want to
solve that can make my work
faster and easier how can I who can help
me what needs to happen in order for me
to solve this faster
do you see how when we ask ourselves
better questions our brain will say well
you could do this and this and this so
and so and so and so can help you so
this is part of the modeling but first
before we do we want to ask better
questions when we ask better questions
we lead ourselves the behavior is in
many cases a better Behavior than the
behavior that we would normally take on
our own right how about number six is
craft a compelling future with Dean
graziosi I like to pretend
it's one year from today
and instead of us looking through the
dust cloud stay with me a minute I know
this might sound a little hokey but
instead of looking through the dust
cloud of what could happen
let's pretend it's a year from now and
we're looking backwards
and let's pretend it was the best year
of your life
what would have to happen in your life
for it to be the best year of your life
in your career or your income or your
business or your relationships or love
or health or joy and I don't want you
your brain's going to go oh I would love
for this happen no no no I want you to
trick your brain
I want you to focus it and live it
positive Focus as if it already happened
take a moment and really visualize
how my my coaching business is launched
I'm coaching I'm coaching a hundred
different people
100 different people are giving me a
thousand dollars each I coach them
monthly and I'm transforming their lives
I get to help them through that trouble
that I figured out in my life
they send me thank you cards they're so
excited that I get to be with them every
single month and transform their life
it's filled my soul
and I get to work from anywhere I want
with this laptop and I can't believe
this became real in my life
I can't believe I get to coach people
for a living that I get to make more do
more be more well simultaneously serving
and living into my full potential God
and I love the fact that I get to make a
hundred thousand dollars a year just
just by serving
that's different than saying I hope to
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
right
so I I'm not trying to oversimplify this
but I want to tell you this has been one
of the biggest game changers in my life
is when I can project myself a year from
now and I'm looking back right I
our relationship has our intimacy back I
can't believe when I walk through the
door the way he looks at me is the way
he used to look at me 15 20 years ago I
can't believe this it's so it gives me
butterflies when he looks in my eyes it
makes me feel like the man I used to be
when my wife looks at me and I know she
knows I have her back I have her back in
a way that I haven't had her back in so
long and she deserved that she's come
alive I see the fire in her eyes
god it feels so amazing and you just
write this down
when it comes to your health I can't
believe I look in the mirror there's me
there she is God I love the way you look
you're at the ideal weight you want to
be not someone else's weight your ideal
weight
this is different than writing down 100
Grand a year getting the best shape ever
uh you know make more money buy the
house
everybody does that and all of them fall
what I want to share with you is
we have the opportunity to pretend it's
a year from now and we're looking
backwards yeah I wrote the book you
could even sue you said my book is
written great your book is done take it
one step further my book is done and
there's people all over the world with
my book in their hands
and they're reading it and they're on
chapter six and they get that story I
never told anybody except when I wrote
in this book and god it feels good when
they hit me up on social media and tell
me about chapter six the more we
visualize the more we have a positive
focus on it the more it's not just this
dream it's our reality that we just
haven't got to yet
when we can when we can see it in our
head
eventually we could hold it and see it
because it's real
so I'd love for you to shift this whole
goals process thing and turn it into a
compelling future and put yourself in
that spot
you could sit and say God I haven't
laughed again
hear me on this I know this might sound
subtle and some of you are probably like
get to the point Dean here's the point
you could say I can't wait to laugh and
smile more in the next 12 months
or you could close your eyes and go oh I
laughed so goddamn much now it's
ridiculous people think there's
something wrong with me I smile so much
oh my god when people I'm so full of joy
I'm so full abundance I feel so
connected to other people I love living
in my full potential but I love it I
smile more than I ever have people think
I'm up to something I'm smiling so much
that's different than saying I'm gonna
smile more put yourself in this spot of
saying it's the best year of my life and
I smile so damn much people think I'm up
to something
when you start visualizing that
you start crafting what that means to
you and that's where you get your goals
you start visualizing the best year of
your life with your career and your
income or your health and your
relationships and your joy
allow yourself to think allow yourself
to be there see it crystal clear
and that's how you craft a compelling
future in habit number seven the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is believe with Bob Proctor my life was
a mess it was a total
it was in a state of chaos absolute
chaos
until I was 26 I wouldn't go to school I
didn't go to school I no formal
education I had no business background
how did your parents feel about you not
going to school well
they didn't seem to my mother raised
three of us on her own okay so and my
dad he didn't I never saw him and mother
was so busy trying to earn enough money
I don't think he'd care she cared you
know I was having trouble in school so
she was probably glad I was getting out
and going to work somewhere
and when I was 26 I had a man that sat
down with me and he said why don't you
change the way you're living
it never entered my mind that I could
and looking back
and thinking about I think there's all
kinds of people wandering the planet
there's all kinds of athletes that are
not getting the results they want and
they don't know they can change them
right only one person can change there's
only one person in the whole universe
that can change Bob and that's Bob yeah
there's only one person can change Dave
and that's Dave
now we get inspired by other people we
get help from other people but we've got
to do it ourselves and he gave me Think
and Grow Rich and he said if you do
exactly what I tell you you can give
anything you want well I didn't believe
that
but he was so adamant about I believed
he believed it
and so
I started to listen to him
and I set a goal I wanted some money I
wanted twenty five thousand dollars now
this was in 1961 so it was more money
than it is today but I didn't even know
anyone with twenty five thousand dollars
he said listen write it on a card keep
reading the book keep doing what I tell
you so I started to hear people talking
about earning money and uh there was one
guy said there's good money cleaning
floors you should clean floors well I
wasn't proud I'd clean floors and he
said but you should do it for yourself
now for somebody else so he told me
where I could buy a used floor machine
some buckets and mops but I had to
borrow a thousand dollars well I was at
the point where nobody wanted to touch
me with money and I often say I wouldn't
have lent it to me right because I
wouldn't pay it back not that I didn't
want to I just couldn't
but I found a guy and he lent me the
thousand dollars
because I have a question because I know
you when you borrowed that thousand
because you owed people money already
you explain that to people you know you
were just finding yourself but did you
have a different feeling about when you
borrowed this thousand that quite
possibly you were actually going to be
able to just to pay this back this time
or something if I hadn't had that
feeling I wouldn't have got the money I
got it from a guy I knew his name Al
Kuiper he was running and I didn't know
him he had a Trust Company it was like a
bank on Den 4th Avenue in Toronto and I
went in I read a book where it says go
to One bank and then give me go to
another one well I ended up sitting in
his office and he said where do you want
this money for son
and I told him I was going to build a
cleaning company and it was going to be
big I had a dream and
I had to explain it all he said I think
you'll do it I'm going to lend you the
money
Faith but I knew when I was doing this I
had a picture I had a dream you see yep
and within a year I was earning 175 000
a year I had my billing up to fifteen
thousand dollars a month working for
myself in less than five years we were
working in Toronto Montreal Boston
Cleveland Atlanta and London England I
had my own company opening offices all
over the place
and I was earning over a million dollars
a year
but I was irresponsible with the money I
would go down to the Playboy there was a
Playboy on Hyde Park right beside the
London Hilton
um when I was young I would have been
your friend
that's what I did with my money early on
I was down I was playing shooting crap I
was playing real life and I didn't care
if I lost it because I knew how to get
more right I knew how to earn money I
didn't realize that was this
skill in itself that not many people
learned and then one day I thought this
isn't this doesn't make sense you know
why am I winning
and I didn't know why and I couldn't
find anybody who could tell me I'd been
raised to believe if you can earn a lot
of money you got to be really smart I
knew I wasn't very smart but I was doing
fairly well I was raised to believe if
you haven't gone to school you'll never
get a good job I didn't have a good job
I owned the company
and I had not I had been to high school
for two months so I knew that was well
then I started to question all kinds of
other things that I believed and most of
them were ridiculous
if you really analyze your beliefs
you'll change them right I had a friend
one time I I was trying to figure out
where do police come from how do you
because all religion and all science
will tell you
you got to believe it William James from
Harvard 1900 he said believe in your
belief will create the fact
so belief is an interesting word you're
going to believe it
and
um
I was having lunch with a mentor one
time and he said our belief system is
based upon our evaluation of something
frequently if we reevaluate a situation
our belief about that situation will
change
it was like Bells were going off my head
because I was trying to understand
belief how do you change your belief
well he told me it's through
re-evaluation and so I started to
evaluate myself
and reevaluate what I was doing it took
me nine and a half years but I figured
out why I changed and it was the
repetition of information
you wanted to be a professional baseball
player yeah right yeah but then you got
an injury I did similar to me so you
never made it to the big league so did
you play minor league I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways you weren't going to be in The
Bigs for I wasn't I played enough
baseball with guys who ended up in the
big leagues to know my limitations yeah
so like anything in life things happen
for you not to you that injury happened
for me it certainly didn't seem like it
at the time but it got me out of that
and into something like what we're
talking about now that completely
changed my life so yeah but yeah I want
to be an athlete for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and I were
just Thomas before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were their career changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever your dream is
when the first one ends it doesn't
happen when that be a relationship it
could be your marriage it ends it was a
dream right or a business venture or a
sport I went into a pretty good
depression and uh and how old were you
at the time 21 22 and I ended up you
know it's because people always see the
after like the house or whatever houses
or whatever the material things are but
I ended up bad man I ended up to press I
ended up moving back at home with my
parents I was living in the city I
remember I was living in this sleeping
in the same bed I grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters I was
like going back in time like six years
on back where I was totally unemployed
and uh couldn't find work didn't have
the motivation to get up and find a job
just sort of eating out of their fridge
and laying around all day so that's
where I was many many years ago after
baseball when you realize things in your
life happen for you truly especially in
hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any
disaster tragedy most people look back
five ten years they think that happened
for me that was actually a good thing
and so I was unemployed I couldn't find
a job and my old man my dad was the best
dad role model you could ever have in
your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me was more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there I said I'm at
mylette I'm here for the job they're
like what job I'm like I don't know just
my dad told me to show up here yeah I
need to ask for Tim they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know it's the last name and
they're like so you showed up for a job
that you don't know what it is and you
don't know who it is it's hiring you I'm
like here's what I know he's an
alcoholic I'm like oh dude yeah we know
that too and so they bring me to the guy
and he says uh you're hired let's go
like literally shakes my hand and you're
hired and he introduces me to these
eight boys that were my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old and
basically I lived with these boys these
precious boys and we ended up adding a
few more my boys were all Wards of the
Court they were all molested by Family
more parents were in prison and so they
had no family and so my whole life
changed all of a sudden these became on
this 22 year old guy these guys become
my sons wow and I did holidays with them
I did birthdays with them I lived with
them literally in a home or like a
little McKinley is a massive campus full
of children that have been displaced
from their homes that live in individual
like Cottages like a foster care
facility massive though really yep all
boys it's in San Dimas here and um wow
it just altered my life man because I
I'd been an athlete had a huge ego had
that mask I wanted to compete I wanted
to win I wanted attention I wanted
recognition first time literally in my
life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they just like man love me believe in me
you know care about me and I had those
eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just
went wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little that I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people you're setting your
expectations too high
you're triggering this sense of
inadequacy in yourself so I will tell
you that kicking yourself in the ass is
super powerful
but my rule is I never do anything that
diminishes my sense of self why because
it actually makes you less effective and
effectiveness at moving towards my goal
is the barometer by which I judge
whether something was a success or not
and if I have made a decision and it
moves me away from my goals because it's
making me feel badly about myself
because I've set a standard that's too
high I'm nitpicking myself to death now
I'm getting worse that's moving me away
from my goal and so I'm not going to do
that I don't allow that in my life I
don't allow it in my life I do not allow
myself to do things that diminish my
sense of self and move me backwards so
when I feel it happening I'm like hey
even if it's true even if I Am The
Biggest Loser That Ever Walked this
Earth reinforcing that myself will make
me capable of less therefore I don't do
it I have a bright line in my life that
says I only do and believe
that which moves me towards my goals so
we're just going to recognize as we set
these expectations that it doesn't make
sense to do anything that diminishes
ourselves so we're not going to set
expectations that are so high that we
know that we are bound to fail or to set
high expectations I love that reach for
the farthest star in the world
but don't value yourself for whether or
not you achieve it value yourself for
the sincere Pursuit meaning you really
showed up you really tried to get to
that far star to achieve some insane
goal it was not rhetoric you really
showed up you got in there you bled for
this thing but the whole time you're
valuing yourself you're cheering
yourself on because you're really trying
you're the man in the arena
covered in Blood Sweat and dirt
you might be getting your ass handed to
you
but you're trying and if you're trying
then you should be rewarding yourself
and if you're rewarding yourself then
you should feel better about it which
makes you more likely to get back in the
ring and fight and if that is the thing
that leads you towards your goals which
of course it is then we know that we are
going to do and believe in that thing
because now we're in the arena we're
fighting our behaviors line up with our
desire to achieve that goal so don't
worry about whether or not you actually
ever get there because let me tell you
success
cannot be guaranteed struggle can you
will struggle I cannot guarantee that
you will be successful
but the juice is never going to be the
success it's never going to be the
accolades just as there is no Feast so
Grand that you will never be hungry
again
there is no accomplishment so profound
that it won't be fleeting
no matter how big no matter how much
money you make
it will never be quote unquote enough
because you're playing a game of
neurochemistry and your neurochemistry
is designed to no matter how big your
meal was last time to get you back out
hunting again it's just how it works all
desire is like that it's cyclical
it'll feel awesome for a minute for a
day for a week maybe a month
but let me tell you you're going to want
to get back out there you're going to
want to hunt you're going to want to
accomplish again so don't value yourself
for that this is how people end up
making a billion dollars only to feel as
lost and empty as ever
you have a hole inside of you that can
only be filled with progress meaning and
purpose it can't be filled with
accomplishment irony of ironies
but that's the way an evolutionarily
derived mind works
you have to be pushed to go on the
journey
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over
satiety
satisfaction contentment
or anathema
to Nature to survival so of course
you're never going to be able to sit in
that
you're going to keep going again and
again and again and again
so Embrace that drive
accomplish huge things if you can
but only value yourself for the sincere
Pursuit one of the things that will help
you to do the work to create the things
that you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool day let's go
do something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen and if you
tell yourself something amazing is going
to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of horsesh everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a
filter in your brain called a reticular
activating system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there you have to make a
decision in your life and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in this sand and
saying here is where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered
it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
foreign
now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open it's heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people you want the best for them
you want the best and you deserve the
best in them if you love them and you
trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them
I don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take I think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage and
and so that's how that looks to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities I know you all have big
goals Big Dreams big aspirations just
like I do you've got Ambitions to become
an amazing person to build your career
to create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you'll you'll fall off and
and having new goals without new habit
it's kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they are the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your your journal or set
up on a vision board that you look at
once in a while but in day-to-day life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this can be so
basic you're going to laugh and then
also tell you how I've literally taught
this to Fortune 50 CEOs and they said it
was the one thing that changed their
life the most dramatically so let's
start with this let's have a goal in
mind let's say you want to become more
present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you can meditate in the morning say
today don't be more present and calm and
you're gonna you could you could start
out with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said
close your eyes
[Music]
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths
and then again it happens at two o'clock
and again it happens at 6 p.m and again
it happens at 8pm
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths reground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that 50
minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right this could be as simple as
let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be
so these are Big crazy things a lot of
people think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
you need to hustle while you wait if
body this advice and apply it to your
business on a day-to-day basis this will
be the biggest momentum shift in your
company this will move you so close to
your goals at an incredible Pace that is
unbelievable just most people don't do
it hustle while you wait listen with
every goal that you have it relies on
other people you need other people to be
a part of your process right if you're
selling to customers you need the
customer to say yes they have to make
their decision there's a bunch of back
and forth if you're waiting on a product
to come you're waiting on your supplier
to come forward there's there's always
things that are outside your control
that you're waiting other people for and
yes when it comes to you you want to get
it done as soon as possible if a
customer is asking for a quote you want
to get it off your plate ASAP you should
not be the bottleneck in momentum
happening in your business that's a
whole other problem as soon as something
comes to you it's getting taken care of
and you're building momentum but you're
still even at the most Peak efficiency
waiting for other people people
to take action that's gonna happen so
what do you do in those moments you
hustle you build new momentum you build
new clients you build new relationships
you maintain the existing ones and get
everything done as soon as possible and
then in the downtime while you're
waiting for a decision you're not just
twiddling your thumbs you're not just
sitting on the couch you're not watching
Netflix you're off hustling new business
quick example I was doing a photo shoot
with Richard this guy's celebrity
photographer he's done Lady Gaga done
the whole bunch of rappers he came over
and we did a photo shoot together and in
between his shots he's got to set up
lights he's gotta get his fog machine
going he's got to get the right angle
he's got to set up the green screen and
so when he needs me I'm there I'm ready
I'm posing I'm in action I'm ready to go
but there's a lot of setup in between
shots and so what am I doing I'm pulling
up my phone and I'm responding to you
guys I'm making videos I'm doing
responses I'm getting on Twitter on
Instagram I'm doing on Snapchat I'm
sending out video responses to you guys
I'm working I'm hustling on my down time
while I'm waiting for Rich for this
project I am hustling connecting with
you guys and that's the approach that
you need to take people say well how do
I find the time to respond to people on
social media I probably have a way
bigger accounts than you guys do and I
find the time because I make the time in
between the other things that I'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time the answer is not to wake up
two hours earlier and think that's going
to solve your problem the answer is
you're losing time every single day you
are leaking valuable time from your
daily schedule and so I highly highly
highly encourage you to take this
message home while you are working while
people are waiting on you for stuff you
are doing your best to deliver as soon
as possible so that you are not the
bottleneck in your business
but then while you're away to another
people you get your hustle on you
continue to build momentum it is such a
hack to get you closer to achieving the
goals that you have for yourself stop
sleeping while you're waiting for other
people to get back to you hustle while
you wait
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to unlock your inner genius check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there planning doesn't
count planning strategizing making ideas
that doesn't count where you're gonna
grow doesn't count you got to do you got
to send an email you gotta make a piece
of content you gotta post something you
gotta follow up with somebody you have
to create you got to make instead of
just living in your head right